troy how far are you into production
before you go
into post and start putting the story
together
it varies on the type of show that
you're doing there are shows that shoot
an episode to a format in just two or
three days
and there are docu-series docu-soaps
where you're in the field for
a total of four months five months
shooting a show
typically what will happen on a
docu-series or a docu-soap
is you'll shoot for three or four weeks
in the field just to get a feel for
what's happening to get your cast used
to the camera
and when you start seeing story come
together that's when it's time to go
back to post
so usually it's a few weeks after you've
started production
at a minimum maybe two weeks and then at
the most you'd want to wait maybe four
or five
um what that enables us to do is to go
back to post and start putting the
stories together
to see if the stories that we're
following are really holding water based
on the content that we've got
if something's not working out there's
still time to call the field and say
listen
this story is dead because everybody is
very
low energy when they talk about it i
don't feel that there's any real
interest there we've got to find
we've got to dig something else out of
them
but again just that short lead just
maybe
two to four weeks of shooting in the
field before you get to post is is
helpful
so if there is a story idea let's
suppose a couple is going to have dinner
how much is something really structured
is it going to be where
great they're going to have dinner but
little things will happen that are going
to be unexpected i mean how much
are you actually really crafting that
well reality television
this is the thing is i always say story
a story and story is written
when you're going in if i have a dinner
scene
i'm following you to dinner but i might
say at the beginning of it listen
over the course of this dinner would you
mind talking about what happened on
thursday
and where you think that's going to go
and also
if you have any plans coming up in the
next two or three weeks can you just
discuss the things that are coming up
so that we can make sure that we have a
starting point for the things that are
coming up
and it's it's very organic and very
natural and someone just says oh yeah we
got to talk about this
um so we're thinking about going out to
the cabin next weekend i don't know if
you want to come with us
it starts a lot of conversation that
leads somewhere
two people hanging out together very
often have a lot of non-sequitur
conversation that isn't always useful
so if you have a couple of objectives
for every scene
it's a little bit different than saying
i'm going to put these words in your
mouth
say this thing i'm telling you to say
but you definitely need to seat it in
order to be able to get useful content
back a lot of the time
so you're giving them an idea and then
those people whoever they are with their
personality and they're bringing it up
in their own manner correct okay
interesting and then you also talk about
sort of walk-ins and walk-offs can you
talk about how you orchestrate those and
where you need them
well i'll tell you anytime that you're
in a new location especially if it's a
place that you're not normally at
um take a little bit of time even if you
don't think you'll use it in post
to shoot a walk up a person arriving at
that location
and going in and also when a person
leaves make sure that you track them to
the door
you can find natural in and out points
during conversations and interactions
i much prefer those to the walk-ins and
walk-outs
but as surely as you don't shoot it
you're going to wish you had it because
sometimes something has to be explained
like i was very upset with
jennifer and i didn't know what i was
going to say to her but i just knew as
soon as i got to the restaurant that i
had to do something
just so we know what's going to happen
to the scene any setup that you need for
a scene has to play
over something and a person walking up
and grabbing the door handle to the
restaurant is the easiest thing in the
world to shoot and it gives you enough
time that you have an interview bite
that you can play against that to set up
your scene before something actually
starts
how many times has this happened where
you have a story idea you have two
people
carrying it out and it takes a totally
different direction or does that happen
all the time it happens all the time
when you go out into the field with a
plan
you're inviting the universe to say fine
you have a plan here's something else
you can't predict human interaction
accurately
you can imagine what's going to happen
when you go out in the field a lot of
the time you'll have a plan for the week
and you'll say well you know monday
we're going to go here tuesday we're
going to do this
thursday we're going to do this you have
a light idea of what people should be
talking about and what's moving forward
and as sure as you do that someone's
going to say
my daughter's getting ready to drop out
of college i gotta get on the phone with
her and talk about it's not anything you
ever imagined you were gonna talk about
and it's not something that you saw as a
story but this is the other reason why
when you are in the field you need to be
able to adapt and be able to follow the
stories that are really happening
in addition to or in place of whatever
the plans are that you had
the best stuff is the stuff that you
don't expect it's always better if
you don't expect it